China having people internally working
on media's or buying media or teachers
or professors or influential people how
much of that is still happening today
it's a huge massive scale not just in
the US but in just about every country
so for example in Canada they had the
sidewinder report from their equivalent
to the CIA which detailed how the
Chinese regime had basically bought off
a lot of politicians in Australia this
is actually discussion in the mainstream
you know news outlets it's it's part of
the cultural discussion right now the
degree to which the Chinese regime has
bought control of their local
politicians that agreed to which the
Chinese regime is able to influence the
society through things like this not
just at the political level but even at
the universities and things like that in
the u.s. I think the discussion is just
starting it's just now being I think the
lid is being opened and I think people
are going to start seeing the extent to
which the Chinese regime has gained
control over a lot of our politicians
has gained control over a lot of the
decision-making this country not just on
the financial level but even on some of
the direct levels when it comes to
things like the Confucius Institutes
Chinese funded you know language and
culture programs at universities where
universities today are taking money from
the Chinese regime when these
Institute's can implement all kinds of
things like censorship and such they're
being called out in a lot of countries
Sweden for example just banned the last
Confucius Institute from the country
when it comes to things like the torch
program the thousand talents program the
973 program the 211 program essentially
a basket of programs the Chinese regime
has official open programs to subvert
our academic institutions and our
business institutions they open they're
open about these things and so the
Chinese regime is very aggressive with
this it not only is it aggressive with
it it does even try to hide it in the US
because for so long it has acted with
audacity it is not afraid you know it
wasn't afraid of people looking into and
trying to figure these things out this
is an example last I checked even what a
few weeks ago the Chinese consulate
website in New York has the United Front
listed as one of its operations it has
the liaison Department listed as one of
its operations the liaison department is
out of the general political department
this is the political warfare branch of
the Chinese military we all heard all
this stuff about you know Russian
disinformation and Russian interference
in our elections China has an entire
military department dedicated to this
the general political department run
through the run through the liaison
department operating openly in New York
City through the Chinese consulate
website there's a think tank project
2049 Institute Institute had a whole
report actually on the liaison
department so how many similarities do
you see for you to make a you know
statement to say you believe they're
gonna go down and they're not gonna stay
like this I'm like similarly do see
between them and Russia pre communism
imposed communism when Russia was going
strong with communism and on all of a
sudden hey you know bring the wall down
and the next thing you know the
philosophy changes this is post
Gorbachev and things start kind of
opening up a little bit more how much
similarity do you see between Russia and
China the old Russia with the current
China the situation is actually very
similar on many fronts and so you know
whereas the Chinese regime has these
systems of overt warfare under under the
Soviets they called that ideological
subversion this unrestricted warfare
program so it so called it ideological
subversion it's the same thing trying
the Chinese regime has carried the torch
of it when it comes to business ties
it's very much the same thing you had a
lot of big corporations manufacturing in
Russia you had a lot of the same you
know overlapping business interests
although on the political level there
was a lot of conflict when it came to
the academic subversion you know the
commmunity communists in the soviet
union were pushing for the global
communist revolution and a lot of
academics and a lot of people in
Hollywood were working with the Soviet
regime and of course at that time if you
were you know a communist party member
for example it meant you were loyal for
the Soviet the Soviet regime the system
is exactly the same the only difference
is that at the time a lot of people
recognized the Soviet Union as a hostile
nation to the United States because you
had threats of nuclear war
a lot more military you know the
perception was a lot more military based
the Chinese regime doesn't have that
perception and so they're able to
operate with a lot more impunity they're
able to operate with a lot you know a
cleaner face essentially for the world
to look at but essentially the situation
underneath the hood is all the same it's
exactly the same and just like the
collapse of the Soviet Union I frankly
believe that the collapse of the Chinese
Communist Party is going to catch a lot
of people by surprise
[Music]